How you doing?
I'm great. What about you? I'm good. I'm
good. You here to destroy God logic?
Yes. By the way, my friend Toa, you just
kicked out for not finishing his point.
So, I'm going to continue in another
topic in another verse. By the way,
let's let's assume that you you refuted
his points on John 8. Well, not we're
not going to assume it's on video. I I
refuted it. If you want to see it, no
problem. No problem. Hold on. Hold on.
Just so just so you can I don't I don't
want I don't want anybody to get
confused on what took place here. Hold
on. I'm not going to kick you out. I'm
just going to show you this.
Are you the same guy by the way? Are you
uh Tola? What are you Ta? No, he's my
friend. Okay. So, let me show you. He's
beside me, by the way. Okay, let me show
you. Let me show you what I'm talking
about. So, this is Cyprien of Carthage.
Okay. Dang, it's uh can't see it. Hold
on. This is Cyprien of Carthage. You see
it?
Okay. All right. So, he's writing and
he's quoting. We go down paragraph
6. He quotes 1 John 5:7 right here.
Look, he says, "And again, it is written
of the Father and the Son and the Holy
Spirit, and these three are one." And he
quotes First John 5:7. Who's this? It's
a Cyprien of Carthage. And who's this?
He's a church. He's a He's a theologian,
an early church writer. Okay. Okay. I
said I said we'll say you refuted his
points. I don't really care about John
5:7. Well, we don't got to say it.
That's that's what happened, right? He
was refuted right there. Right. Okay.
So, where do you get where do you get
the authentic teachings of Jesus?
Can I answer? Can I tell my point first?
That well that's what we're that's what
that's what we were trying to figure
out. Where do you get the authentic
teachings of Jesus my brother? Okay.
From Quran. Yeah. Now let's me from the
Quran.
Oh yes. Okay. So for example the Quran
says yeah just one second. The Quran
says that Jesus says that Ahmed will
come after him. That a messenger named
Ahmed will come after him. Where did
Jesus ever say this? Okay. Is everything
Jesus said recorded?
Yes. When he when he talked about
revelation is revelation. Yes. He
recorded it. So where did Jesus say
this?
Everything he said is recorded. Yes.
When it comes to prophecies in
revelation 100%. So where did Jesus say
this?
So no not everything he said is
recorded. Does the Wait, let me ask you.
Does the verse that saying
uh I think it's uh I don't know. Where
did Jesus say this verse? I just want to
know where he It says that uh Jesus
confirming the Torah, I think. And
uh I think that what it say uh saying
there's a prophet will be named Ahmed.
But it is not really saying that it is
written in the Torah or in his angel.
So where does he by the way? Okay. Oh,
so wait hold on just just a quick. So
Jesus is giving a
revelation where when Jesus gives
revelation is he speaking of his own
self or is this what is this the
revelation that God gave him?
Yes. God gave him the revelation of
course. And where did God what what was
it what was the revelation of God that
that he gave to Jesus
that there will be a prophet name? No,
no, I mean like what what what was the
revelation given to Jesus? The
scripture, you mean? Mhm. Okay. The All
right. So, the revelation of God that
Jesus went around preaching about, we
would it's part of the Would you agree?
What what's he the revelation that Jesus
was going around preaching when it came
to revelation would be the correct? Yes.
He was preaching orally. So if Jesus is
giving revelation of a prophet to come
after him that would be in the in right?
Uh yes the angel is the scripture the
revelation given to him. So yes very
good. So where in the can you show me
where Jesus actually said this where he
said that Ahmed is going to come after
him?
Uh he said the rea the revelation that
was given to him by God.
Uh thank you. Okay. Which which tells
him which yes which tells him that there
will be a prophet named Ahmed.
So so when you ask me where is it in the
in
uh uh as I said the angel he was
preaching it
orally. So you're telling me where did
Jesus say this? It it is written it is
written in in the in an actual book a
physical book. I don't really know.
Okay. Well, the Quran says that the was
written down. So according to the Quran,
since the was written down and it was
with the
Christians, that's what I'm asking
about. What were they opening up? What
were they opening that they can open up
and they had the gospel in the seventh
century and they can find Jesus saying
that Ahmed is going to come after him
because what they had in the seventh
century it's not really what's called
the angil that was given to Jesus
himself
and we are told to judge by the the
scripture you have today by the Quran no
you're not but there's no the what you
just said that the Quran doesn't say
that. It says the opposite. What what
what I'll show you in a second. I'll
show you in a second. Okay. But just
dealing with the first point and then we
could deal with what you're supposed to
judge by. I I'll show you that. Trust
me. The first point though is that uh
you said that the NGO that the
Christians had Are you texting him or is
he texting you giving you what to say?
What did he say? Sir, you I heard you.
Are you texting?
Oh, yes. I'm doing some research.
You said that the angil that Jesus was
preaching was different than the angel
that the Christians had. Correct. Uh
what they have is not even the but okay.
Okay. So why does the Quran say that
they have the angel then? They have the
Yeah. Why does it say they have it? They
have it in their hands. Yes.
Say the Okay. Show me. You want to see
it? Yes. I want to see. Maybe I don't
know. Maybe you know more than me. Okay,
tell me just a little bit. But will you
first will you let me talk about uh the
points my friend did about the
youngest? You acknowledge that he got
debunked.
No, I'm talking about other verses
because there are literally tens of
verses that have been added. Do you know
Do you know why we even got to that
subject?
Do you know what? You know why we got to
that subject?
I don't know what he actually what he
actually said. We got we got there
because of this because we're trying to
figure out what did Jesus actually
preach. And so he was saying that the
Bible that I have is unreliable when it
comes to teachings of Jesus. So this is
where the conversation was going. So
you're in line and on topic just now
it's you got to demonstrate what you're
saying. You know I I allowed the talking
about the Bible manuscripts for a
second. I allowed that for that. But
this is the main crux of the issue here.
So you want Okay. So you won't let me
talk about the other verses like Mark
16:9 to20. That if you want if you want
to if you want to have that view, fine.
You got it. You're just going to have to
tell me then what is the authentic
teaching of Jesus? Bible's corrupted.
Bible's corrupted. Bible's been changed.
Okay. Okay. Okay. You agree with that?
Okay. Good. I don't agree with it. I'm
just saying it doesn't help you. It
doesn't help you at all. If I'm giving
you the point, it still doesn't help
you. I don't really care. I'm just
saying I'm finishing her point. Her
point his point. No, his point there are
first. Don't kick me. Please don't kick
me. I know. I'm not going to kick you.
I'm going to show you your Quran first.
I got You kick so many people. I do. I
kick them off. I I I kick people who are
dishonest and and arrogant. That's all.
who can't engage. Okay? If you're if you
if you can engage, if you can engage,
you can stay as long as you want. So,
look, this is chapter 7 verse 157.
It says, uh, why would it not? Not not
this version. Hold
on. Come on,
guys. Give me something. Give me
something. Where's Hal? There you go.
Here it is. So, you see the screen? Yes.
Those who follow the messenger, the
prophet who can neither read nor write.
I'm not going to read the parenthesis,
by the way, because that's not in the
scripture. Those who follow the
messenger, who can neither read nor
write, whom they find written with them
in the
Torah and the
gospel. Now, it is funny how they quote
my Bible that I have today, but you
know, that's neither here nor there. Um,
so the Quran says that the Injil is
written and is with them, right?
Okay.
So my question is because you said that
the Injil that the Christians had or you
were they didn't have it but now we see
that they actually did have it. So they
had the Injil given to Jesus, right?
What? They had the Injil, right?
According to this verse. Okay, let me
look at it. Let me check. You're looking
at it.
Yeah, I'm reading it in Arabic, then
seeing the translation Quran.com. So,
don't I'm not saying you're lying or
something, but you want the Arabic? I
could just put the Arabic up here for
you if you want the
Arabic. Where is the There it is. Here's
the
Arabic. Does it say Men in the
Uh yes, I gota admit that it says McKen.
Yes. So Maktuben written in with them.
Okay.
So they have it with them. They have the
gospel of Jesus and it's in written form
and they have it. I gota Yes. I gota
admit that. I didn't know that. That's
why I said perhaps you might know
something more than me. Fair enough. But
I also say I also say that the Quran
tell us tells us to judge between those
scriptures with the Quran itself. Okay.
So let's go ahead and do this. Let's go
to that step now because I can see that
you could be honest. So I have no
problem going there with you. Okay.
Where does the Quran say? Matter of
fact, I'm going just skip all these
steps. Let's go to where you what you
what you think the Quran is saying. I'm
gonna go to 548. That's the verse you're
quoting.
548. And by the way, there's nowhere in
your Quran where it says, "Use the Quran
to judge the scriptures." All right.
There's what? No. No verse in the Quran
that says what? That says to use the
Quran to jud as a judge of the previous
scriptures. It doesn't say that. Okay.
Okay. What does it say? So, this is 548.
This is what you're referring to.
It says, "And we have sent down to you
the book in truth confirming the
scripture that came before it and a
Mahiman, right, a guardian or
trustworthy witness, right, over it. So
judge between them by what Allah has
revealed and follow not their vain
desires, diverging away from the truth
that has come to you." So notice what it
says to judge not the scriptures but the
people and their desires. Right?
So judge between them by what Allah has
revealed and follow not their vain
desires diverging away from the truth
that has come to you. It refer to it
refers to the scriptures by the way. Oh.
So do the scriptures have vain desires?
Books have vain desires. No, it
literally it literally refers to it. It
refers to it. I I understand when it
says so judge between them, you're
saying that them is the scriptures.
Uh judge between
them. Okay, let me see. So, you see how
it's not talking about the books, but
it's talking about people, right? You
did you did say it doesn't say don't uh
judge. It doesn't say judge between the
scriptures. Correct. And I did say it
does. No, it doesn't. Okay. All right.
Stop. Where does it say to judge the
scriptures?
Uh, come for it over here. So, judge
between them. Who's the them? I guess it
refers to the Torah and the Okay. So,
let's go with you that it's referring to
the Torah and Gospel. Judge between them
by what Allah has revealed and follow
not their vain desires. So the Torah and
the Gospel have vain desires. They want
things.
Right? So books don't have desires.
People do. Right?
Okay. So it's not talking about judging
the scriptures, but judging the people.
So judge between them by what Allah has
revealed and follow not their vain
desires, diverging away from the truth
that has come to you. Okay. Doesn't this
uh really
uh disprove that their book is not what
they used to uh judge Ruth? Yeah, it is.
Look, verse 47, we go just the verse
before it says, "Let the people of the
gospel judge by what Allah has revealed
therein." Yeah, I know, right? So, they
have to judge.
according to then it says
uh uh judge between them with what Allah
has revealed to you i.e. the Quran.
Who's the them? Or again, who's the
them?
I did say according to you, it means
to I'm not really sure if
u uh if them really refers to the people
of the scripture. It refers to the
people of the scripture, brother. But
yes, but if but
uh if it does refer to them,
uh then uh it says that we should judge
between them with the Quran.
between the people, right? With the
Quran. Yes, I agree. But it's the people
that you have to judge with the Quran,
not the scriptures. Okay. So, now let me
show you the other way around. Let me
show you that it's the previous
scriptures that we have to use as a
judge over the Quran. You want to see
that? Sure, why not?
Okay. So, if we go
to
1094, you're so you're you're so nice,
by the way. The fact that you call
yourself God logic destroyer is crazy,
but I like it.
I don't really mean anything
disrespectful to you, by the way. I
know. I see. You don't you don't have a
disrespectful bone in your body right
now. Okay. I I was really I want to
destroy you about the money script
topic, but you didn't you did not let me
talk about it. Oh, no. Stop it. Yeah.
And tell your fans to stop insulting me
in the comments. Guys, leave him alone.
He's been nice. Yes. Yes. Yes. Good
boys.
All right. So, it says
here, this is chapter 10 verse 94. It
says, "If and if you are and if you are
in doubt concerning that which we
revealed unto
you, then question those who read who
read the scriptures before you. Verily
the truth from your Lord has come to
you, so be not of the
waverers."
So Allah says to
Muhammad, "If you're in doubt about what
we have revealed to you, which is the
Quran, right? Allah revealed the Quran
to Muhammad. Correct.
Uh the Quran. Yes. Okay. So pay pay
attention brother. So he revealed
Muhammad to Muhammad the Quran. And he
says if you're in doubt about what we've
revealed to you which mean meaning the
Quran. Then go and ask those who've been
reading the scripture before you. It
truly huh? It refers it refers to the
stories. Let's let's even go with that.
Let me give you that is referring to the
stories. How will Muhammad know that the
Quran is correct regarding these sto the
stories of the previous uh people and
the previous prophets? How will you know
what? How will he know that the Quran is
correct when it's talking about the
previous stories of the prophets and
stuff?
Uh since he received the revelation.
Well, he is received the revelation but
he might have doubt from God.
Well, he already received it from God.
Look, look, what does Allah tell him to
do in case he's doubting the Quran? What
does he What does Allah tell him? Yes.
He's uh basically telling him to make
sure like to
uh to make him really see that the Quran
is from God. Yes. How how will he see
that the Quran is really from God? What
does he tell him to do to make sure he
can see that the Quran is really from
God?
Uh it says ask the
uh ask those uh scriptures before you.
Exactly. So what will what will
determine like for Muhammad if the Quran
is correct and it's really from God? Is
it the Quran itself or is it the
previous scriptures?
Quran
itself. My brother test here. Come on.
Muhammad's Muhammad might be doubting
like this is an if. Muhammad might be
doubting the Quran according to this
verse. If you are in doubt about the
Quran, right?
Yes, it does say that. Okay. So, if
you're in doubt about the Quran, Allah
says, "Go ask those who read the
scripture before
you." Why? What would reading the
scripture before him, how will that help
his doubt that he might have in the
Quran?
Uh so he's telling him
uh to check the stories that that's in
the Quran by seeing them in the in their
books which is so that's in their books.
Good. So that means so what would clear
up any doubt that he might have in the
Quran? What would clear up his doubt?
uh by checking their checking what their
uh books. Correct. So if the Quran is in
line with the previous books in the
regarding these stories, then he'll know
that the Quran is true. Right.
Yes. In the story. Okay. Correct. If the
if he checks the previous scriptures and
the Quran is not in line with these
stories, then he'll know that the Quran
is false. Right.
Uh, you know, the Quran is false. If it
doesn't line up, if these stories don't
line up with the previous scriptures,
right?
Okay.
So, what is the So, here we are. This is
where we're at. If Muham if the Quran
lines up with the previous scripture,
then Muhammad will know the Quran is
true. If the Quran does not line up with
the previous scripture regarding these
stories, then Muhammad will know that
the Quran is false. So what is the judge
on whether or not the Quran is true? The
Quran or the previous scriptures in this
case?
Uh in judgment you know you mean
what is the deciding factor if the Quran
is true or not regarding these stories?
Is it the Quran itself? No, but the
previous the judgment doesn't say uh
something about confirming that it's
true in the verse that uh if you have
doubt in something then you're doubting
its truthfulness. Correct. You you you
don't fully believe its truthfulness.
Right?
Okay.
So Muhammad is making a judgment on
whether or not the Quran is true
regarding these stories.
Allah tells him the way that he can
figure this out is if he checks the
previous scriptures. Right?
Okay. So the judge on whether or not the
Quran is true or false regarding these
stories is the previous scriptures.
Right?
The to
judge to judge that to judge if there to
judge if the Quran is true or false.
It's the previous scriptures regarding
these stories. Right. Okay.
Yeah. Okay. Yes. So, according to the
Quran, according to the Quran, it's not
the Quran that judges the previous
scriptures. It's the previous scriptures
that judge the Quran. Now, if I want to
go with you and say, "Oh, well, it's
only pertaining to these to the stories
of the previous prophets." Fine. I'll
give you that. That still shows that the
previous scriptures regarding the
stories of the previous prophets, right?
what they taught, what they did, what
happened with them, the
revelations. It's the previous
scriptures that judge the Quran in these
matters, not the other way around.
Yeah.
So if I check the previous scriptures
and I see the that the Quran gets these
stories wrong and gets these prophets
wrong and there's history, then I can
judge that the Quran is false and not
really from
God.
Uh okay, that's a really good point that
just because I uh I don't really know
about this verse to be honest.
Yeah. Well, if you if you look at Ibath,
um are you familiar with with Ibadir?
What are you familiar with Iben Cadir?
His taps. Uh yes, I know him. I know.
Okay. He he talks about how it's not
really just about their the stories, but
it's also about the prophecies about
Muhammad within their scriptures. That's
what he said.
That's what he said. He said what? So
Ibath he says that this verse doesn't
just refer to the stories of the people
in the past the past stories but it also
refers to the prophecies of Muhammad in
the previous
scriptures. So basically when Allah says
that you know Muhammad's in their
scriptures that they can find him
written in their Torah in the gospel u
where Jesus mentioned him or you know
stuff like
that he can check the previous
scriptures and see that this actually is
true that the Quran got that stuff
right. If he's not mentioned in the
previous scriptures then he'll know that
the Quran is false and that the
revelation he's receiving is not really
from God.
That's a big reason
why says Yeah. So I when he pulls it
out, let me just show you. Okay. He
Okay. Show me the the
Yeah. So when we go to the top of watch
what he does here. He um lain this
I previous books attest to the truth of
the
Quran. Right? So quoting these verses,
watch what he quotes. He
quotes, he attaches surah 757 to it,
right? Those who follow the the
messenger, the prophet who can neither
read nor write, whom they find written
with them in the Torah and the NGO.
7157. So he attaches 7157 to this verse
and he says they are as certain of this
of what? That Muhammad is in their Bible
is in their scriptures. They are as
certain of this as they are about who
their who their children are. Yet they
hide it and distort it. They did not
disbelieve in it despite its clear
evidence. Right? Therefore, Allah said
and he continues talking about the wrath
that goes upon them for not for not
believing this. Okay?
So so uh Ibeka says that this is also
about the prophecies of Muhammad in the
previous scriptures. You get what I'm
saying?
So if
Muhammad is not prophesied in the
previous scriptures like the Quran
says, it's not that the Quran judges the
previous scriptures. No, it's the
previous scriptures that judge the
Quran. And so if he's not in there, then
we can judge that the Quran is false.
Okay. Okay. Let me let me see
the because I can't really find it here.
Right here. It's on the screen, bro. No,
no, no. I'm searching for it. I don't
know what the website you're using or
the app you're using. This is
quranex.com. Uh what what website are
you on? Are you on quran.com?
No,
don't Arabic website.
Um if you want
I can go to
Let me see. I can do this. Hold on.
Tough Syrian
Arabic. We can pull this. What is What
is this app? Say that again. The app.
What is this? What What is it? Oh, the
website. The Is that a website or I know
this is a website.
It's a website. Quran Quranx.com.
Quranex.com.
Mhm. You don't You don't trust what I'm
showing you on the screen, man?
I'm checking. Wait, I'm not saying.com.
Mhm.
Okay. Okay.
You found
it. Let me see.
Uh, I'm just looking for the family.
Mhm. But I don't. Do you know how to use
it? But I don't. No. No. So look. So
what you're going to do? Yeah, but I I
see of many other
scholars
like they say
okay then with this knowledge that they
know
from that they know from from their
books as they know their own children.
Yeah. So he says they distort it. They
they distort it and they change it and
do not believe in it despite the proof
of being established against them
against. Yeah. They don't they don't
believe in it even though they even
though it's in their scriptures for it
said they change it. Yeah. That's what
he says. They distort it and they change
it even though it's there and they don't
believe in it. And for this and for this
reason they
say and for
this one let me uh see the rest.
I'm confused. What are you looking at?
I'm checking the verses in Arabic
because
uh try to see something and see the
other sayings by other scholars. Yeah,
it says the same thing in Arabic. I have
I have it in Arabic on the screen if you
want. It's right there.
Yeah.
Shoot up.
Okay. So, it says here, as I said
before, they change it and destroy
it. Uh,
and they do not believe in him even
though the proof has been established
against them. Right. No, here it refers
to a verse. But yeah, 757
57 one. It refers to Allar chapter 7
verse 157.
That's the verse that I showed you where
it says that the angel is written and is
with them and they can find Muhammad
written in their scriptures. I'm not
talking about this verse. Well, that's
what he references.
Okay. So, let let go of the verse. They
say
They change it. Uh their own shall they
destroy it and change it and do not
believe in it despite the proof being
established against them. Mhm.
I have that right here. Is that what is
saying? Yeah.
What does he say? That's what he said.
You just said it.
He said that. Yes. It's right here on
the screen.
Is this the
brother? Do do you are you playing with
me? No. No. I'm asking. Seriously. Wait.
This is I
taps. It's I taps breaking down 1094.
All
right. He even quotes Ibn Abbas from S.
Benjubar and Al Hassan Albasari said the
same. Right. And this is they said that
this is to strengthen this is they're
saying this is to strengthen the umah
and inform them that the description of
their prophet may Allah bless him and
grant him peace is found in the previous
books in the hands of the in the hands
of the people of the book. Okay,
continue or you can just scroll down to
show it and read it. Then despite the
not
change. Okay. Is that what you say? So
your point was that the previous
scriptures are uh what we use to judge
uh whe whether the Quran is true or not
is the previous scripture. Okay. And the
tier
says says that even though even though
they recognize him in their books, they
change it and the story.
Okay. So uh
uh wait. So according to the verse, it's
the Bible. It's the previous scriptures
that's the authority on whether or not
the Quran is true concerning that
they're changing
and the Quran doesn't say that they
changed it. No, you you brought the for
of Yeah, I did. Yes. According according
to to his
uh it's here talks about the prophecies
of prophet Muhammad in the books, right?
Yep. Okay. And it say that they changed
it and distorted. Yeah, he would have to
prove that. Okay. So when they when when
uh Kasir himself is saying that these
things are being changed,
so how come we can rely on his to say
that their books are the books that we
used to judge whether the Quran is false
or true? Well, we're just going off the
Quran. I'm not I I just used Ibath to
supplement the point for you. Yes, use
you use. So I'm also going to use Yeah,
you can use Ibikir. So according to even
what Ibek says, the judge is the Bible,
right?
It's the Bible. Yeah, the previous
scriptures, right? It talk about the
prophecies.
They change it. The prophecies where?
Yes. In the in their books. Okay. So
since it's in their books, their books
are the authority on whether or not the
Quran is true or not regarding these
things. Correct?
Yes. Their original books. Okay. Not the
original ones, the ones they have with
them because even I says they have they
have it in their hands.
The ones that they change and distort.
What are Okay. So So these in these
distorted books, it still has Muhammad
written in them.
No. According to him, according to Okay.
Well, according to Ibicus, he says, look
what he says here. He says this is to
strengthen the um and inform them that
the description of their prophet, may
Allah be blessed and peace be upon him,
is found in the previous books in the
hands of the people of the book. They
have
it. So if so, and then in the in the
next breath, he says that they changed
it. So the books that they have in their
hands are changed yet they still contain
Muhammad's prophecies in them. This is
No, I didn't say that. No, this is
saying this is saying that even though
they change it on the story, Muhammad is
still mentioned there. Okay. So then
these corrupted scriptures, I'm asking,
brother, you you're reading it, right?
Right. This this is the last time I go
because I feel like you're playing games
with me. No. I'm not playing games with
Okay. Okay. Does it Does it say here
that Muhammad is found in their previous
books in their hands? Yes. Okay. Okay.
And then he quotes the verse to back it
up. Then he says, "Then despite this
knowledge, they recognize him from their
books as they recognize their own
children. They confuse it, distort it,
and change it. And they do not believe
in him even though the proof has been
established against them." So they have
the scripture and they have Muhammad's
prophecies. Yet he says they distort and
change them. Right. Okay. So even in
their changed books, their distorted
revelation, they still have Muhammad's
prophecies in them in their possession.
Correct. When he say they they
recognize, they confuse it, distort, and
change it. So doesn't that basically
means that they are removing this
prophecies from their own book? No, it
doesn't mean they're removing it. It
means that they're misinterpreting and
lying about what this stuff says. No, it
says change it. Okay. So accordion.
Let's go with you. Let's go with that.
It's changed. So according to the the
verse, Allah is telling Muhammad to go
check a changed
book to clear up his doubts about the
Quran.
Uh if you're using
Okay. Uh use where he said the
prophecies. Just just if we go with
view, let's go with their view. It's
changed. It's corrupted. It's changed.
So according to the verse, Allah is
sending Muhammad to check changed
corrupted books if he has doubts in the
Quran. Correct.
The
[Music]
I just really don't understand
something. You say that. Take care, bro.
Take
care. Take care. You can play as dumb as
you want.
You can play as dumb as you want, bro.
Take care of yourself.